Welcome students
to the second part
of our pharmacodynamics
lectures.
In this lecture,
we will talk about
quantifying agonism
and antagonism,
various models,
receptor dynamics,
and pharmacodynamic
variability in a
population. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
I extend an
invitation for a
pharmacology chat.
If you would like
groups or individuals,
all welcome.
Just email me and we'll
set up an appointment
that's convenient for
both or all of us.
Here are the learning
objectives. Just to
remind you, this is
the answer to the
question, what do I need
to know? now, so that
you can focus your
studies and try and
avoid going down rabbit
holes. As interesting
as they are, they can
take up your time.
Compare and contrast
the actions and effects
of agonists and
antagonists as illustrated
by specific concentration
effect curves.
We talked about
those dose-response
relationships concentration
effect curves in
the part one lecture
and now we're going
to apply it to agonists
and antagonists.
We're going to talk
about them in the context
of the classical
receptor occupancy model
and the two-state
receptor occupancy model.
We're going to talk
about competitive
antagonists, non
-competitive antagonists,
negative and
positive allosteric
modulators, and
spare receptors as
demonstrated in
experimental sample models.
We're going to relate
the drug action,
receptor occupancy,
receptor response,
and receptor
regulation based on
concentration effect
curves and receptor
binding of agonists
and antagonists.
And finally,
we will explain the
pharmacodynamic variabilities
in a population
and calculate the
therapeutic index when
given the quantal dose
response curves. These
are the things that
you should be able to
do after you've become
familiar with the
concepts in this lecture.
And here are the
preparation materials in
the CPG and also on
these slides. Scholar
Rx Bricks, Practice
questions are required.
All the rest is at
your own choice.
Whatever works for
you. You will have
to acquire the
knowledge, so do that
in the way that
works best for you.
Here are our links
to textbooks and
our receptor
occupancy model. These
are what you need
to learn about.
I'm not going to
read these slides.
You can read them
yourself perfectly well.
Classical receptor
occupancy model.
Other mechanisms of drug
antagonism.
Receptor dynamics.
You'll hear
about receptor
desensitization,
downregulation, tachyphylaxis,
disease, receptor
resensitization,
supersensitivity,
and pharmacodynamic
variability in
a population.
You can think about
animal experimentation,
you can think about
clinical trials.
So let us begin with
our receptor occupancy
models of agonists
and antagonists.
The two that
we'll talk about,
which are two
basics and as you
read about more
going through
your practice
life, your lifelong
learning, you'll
see others but
you can build on
these two models.
They propose explanations
of the activity
of drugs at receptors.
And these are
founded in abundant
experimentation.
So the two-state
receptor occupancy model,
I'm going to mention
that one first,
postulates
that the receptor assumes
two conformational
states, active and
inactive, in the
absence of a ligand.
So, it can be either
in an active state
or an inactive state.
We're talking about an
entire pool of receptors.
So this is called
the receptor pool.
And some of the receptors
in that pool are
in a conformational
state that's active and
it's going to produce
some basal activity.
Many receptors, I should
say many cells, need
to have some sort of
constitutive activity
in order for
us to function
as human beings,
as organisms.
And some of them
are going to
be in an inactive
conformation.
The receptor can
activate downstream
mechanisms that produce
a small observable
effect even in the
absence of a ligand
and it has constitutive,
other people
say constitutive,
or basal activity.
So that's what
we mean with the
two-state receptor
occupancy model.
There is a total
receptor pool.
Some of the
receptors are in an
active form
producing some basal
amount of activity
and and the others
are in an inactive
conformation.
Now the classical
receptor occupancy
model, which actually
did come first,
postulates that
receptors in a
receptor pool
are quiet unless
they are activated
by a ligand.
That ligand is usually
some natural molecule,
an endogenous molecule,
let's say epinephrine.
I used that as an
example before. 4.
Agonists bind to
receptors and stimulate
the signal transduction
pathways. Agonists
have affinity and
intrinsic activity.
5. Antagonists bind
to receptors and
inhibit or block the
biologic responses
by interfering
with the agonist's
ability to activate
the receptor. here.
Antagonists have
affinity, they will
bind, and the receptor
will bind to them,
but they have zero
intrinsic activity.
They are not causing
the receptor to
activate its downstream
effector mechanism.
And at the same
time, they block
the agonist from
occupying the
site, inhibitors
or blockers.
So let's take a look
at curves in the two
-state model of drug
receptor interaction.
The hypothetical
receptor is able to
assume two conformations,
I explained
that before. So,
on this figure,
we have our active
confirmation or
inactive confirmation.
And here we have our
drug coming in, and
the drug can bind to the
inactive confirmation
and hold it there,
or drug can bind to
the active confirmation
and hold it there.
So, let's take a look
now at these curves.
Talking about a drug.
So a drug that is a
full agonist, you can
see it's producing the
maximal effect, Emax.
The drug will bind to
the receptor in the
active conformation.
It has affinity for
the receptor in the
active conformation.
That's the affinity
that it has.
So it will shift
almost all of
the receptors
in the pool to
the active plus
drug complex,
activating the receptor
-effector systems
to the maximal
effect. Now let's
take a look at the
second curve down.
Here we have a drug
that will bind to
the active
conformation of the
receptor, but it will
also bind to a certain
extent the inactive
conformation.
So partial agonists
have a slightly
greater affinity for
the active conformation
than for the inactive
conformation. And
what is the effect
that we would see?
They do not
stabilize the active
conformation as much as
the full agonists do.
Therefore, a
significant fraction
of the receptors
is in the
inactive drug
complex form.
As a result, there
is some effect, but
it's not the full
effect. It's not
maximal efficacy,
it's a partial effect.
Therefore a partial
agonist produces
only the partial
effect. Now I'd
like, well I'll
point that out later.
Now a neutral antagonist,
here we have our
baseline constitutive
activity, a neutral
antagonist will
have equal affinity
for both the
active confirmation
and the inactive
confirmation.
And what it will
appear is that the
drug has no
effect. So if this
particular drug that
has the equal affinity
is injected into
an animal model
and we're looking
to see what happens,
it looks like
nothing changes.
Whatever
constitutive activity
was going on
continues to go on.
No change.
So it looks
like nothing is
happening. But
the drug is bound.
It's an antagonist
and it's bound to the
receptors and it will
prevent the agonist,
the full agonist or
the partial agonist
from binding. So it
is still inhibiting.
Now the inverse
agonist, I know
this is kind of
a confusing term,
the inverse agonist
will bind to the
inactive conformation
with much higher
affinity than it binds to
the active conformation
and therefore the
inverse agonist
will stabilize the
large fraction of the
receptors in the
inactive conformation.
So what do we see? What
does the researcher
see when the animal
is injected with
a drug that is an
inverse agonist? It will
show that there
is a decrease in
constitutive activity.
The effect decreases,
resulting in the effects
opposite from the
agonist. So it looks
like an inhibitor.
The observable
effect is that of
an inhibitor.
Nothing is happening.
Now the classical
receptor occupancy model,
this is how we talk
about mainly the
classification of
antagonist. So I want you to
just put this whole
two receptor occupancy
model, two receptor
confirmation occupancy
model aside for a moment.
Now you're thinking
about it in a completely
different way.
Competitive antagonists
compete for the
same binding site as
the agonist. So, that's
called the active
site. The agonist binds
to the active site,
produces an effect.
A competitive
antagonist will also
bind to the active
site, but it
will produce no
effect, and it will
prevent the agonist
from binding.
Pretty simple.
It's competitive,
so it associates,
dissociates,
associates, dissociates.
Now, a noncompetitive
antagonist will reduce
the magnitude of
the maximal response
that can be achieved by
any amount of agonist
without having an
effect. In other words,
it's an inhibitor, it
will block the effect
of the agonist but in
a different way than
the noncompetitive
antagonist does. So, we're
going to get into
more detail with that.
I want to draw
your attention to
this figure that
shows these various
actual mechanisms
of antagonism.
Receptor antagonists,
in other words,
they are antagonists
at the receptor.
And we also have non
-receptor antagonists,
they're antagonists
by a non-receptor
mechanism. them,
I'm not going to
go into them right
now, I will later.
So the antagonist
binds to the
active site,
it can bind by
far and away,
the most common
is reversible binding,
association, dissociation,
association,
dissociation, that's a
competitive antagonist.
Now, there are a few
that will bind
irreversibly to the active
site, and because it's
occupying that site
irreversibly, the
agonist cannot get to it.
And then there's the
allosteric binding,
which means to a
neighboring site, it's not
the active site, and
it will cause, it will
bind and cause a
conformational change such
that But the agonist
is unable to bind with
its usual affinity to
the active site and
therefore does not
activate the receptor.
Now these two can
be reversible and
irreversible,
and these are
noncompetitive
allosteric antagonists.
So we have curves
to demonstrate what
we're talking
about. Let's start
with the competitive
antagonist, which
is illustrated in
the top figure.
Competitive here.
This is the
active site here.
And you can see
they both have
affinity for
the active site.
Now how do we demonstrate
this experimentally?
With our agonist
curves. So here's
the starting point,
right here, the
control they call
it. So that's the
agonist is injected
and we see some
response, here's our
maximal response,
that occurs at
this concentration.
Now, if a competitive
antagonist is
injected into this
animal, and then,
this is a certain
concentration and then
the agonist is injected
again, now at a
higher concentration,
the agonist will be
able to out-compete
the antagonist at the
receptor site and
again produce the
maximal effect, but we
see it takes a greater
concentration of
agonist to achieve
that. And more competitive
antagonist, again
achievable with a
greater concentration
of the agonist, etc.,
on down the line.
This is an
experimental situation
to demonstrate
that a competitive
antagonist can
be outcompeted
if the concentration of
agonist is high enough.
Now an irreversible
active site
antagonist is
indicated here.
It binds to the active
site, the agonist
cannot bind, and with
increasing concentrations
of irreversible
antagonist, the
effect is totally
reduced, agonist effect.
Now here we have a
positive allosteric
modulator. Now this
is not an inhibitor.
It's actually
activating the receptor.
So what's happening
here? receptor.
This is our
control again.
This would be
the regular Emax.
A drug that binds to
an allosteric site,
so it's a neighboring
site and it's going
to cause a conformational
change in the
receptor active site
such that it actually
enhances the affinity
of the agonist,
whether that's a
natural receptor agonist
or a drug, so that
it produces an effect
that's above the usual
maximal effect. So
this is a positive
allosteric modulator.
It's producing a
positive effect on the
receptor's action. A
negative allosteric
modulator, now this is
going to be an inhibitor,
is going to bind to
the allosteric site,
the neighboring site
near the active site
and cause a conformational
change in the
active site such that
the affinity is reduced
for the agonist and
the efficacy for the
agonist is reduced.
And here we have this,
this is control, the
usual Emax right here.
And with the reduction
in the affinity
for the site,
depending on how much
allosteric modulator
is there and whether
or not it's reversible,
it will cause a
decrease in the
effect of the agonist.
so that is the classic
receptor theory up
till now we've been
talking about antagonism
by drugs at the
same receptor as the
drug of interest receptor
mediated antagonism
These other mechanisms
are different.
They are not receptor
-mediated. The
antagonist drug will
act at a totally
different receptor,
possibly even
a totally different
organ system.
So a physiologic
antagonist, called
often a functional
antagonist, is a
substance that
produces physiologic
effects that
are opposite the
physiologic effects
of another substance.
In other words,
their functions are
different. They act on
different regulatory
pathways mediated by
different receptors.
Typical examples
are insulin,
which reduces
blood sugar, and
glucagon, that
increases blood sugar.
Methacholine, which
is a drug that
causes
bronchoconstriction, while
albuterol causes
bronchodilation.
Opposite effects.
A chemical antagonist
is a compound
that directly interacts
with the agonist,
such that the
agonist is no longer
able to travel to and
bind its receptor.
The combination product
is inactive and excreted.
Examples here are heparin
bound by protamine,
divalent cations
and antacids
that chelate
certain drugs,
tetracycline being
a typical example,
Cholestyramine,
that is an exchange
resin that
sequesters drugs.
Cholestyramine
is not absorbed,
therefore the drugs
are not absorbed.
And I will elaborate on
these mechanisms here.
Insulin is secreted from
the endocrine pancreas.
It acts on insulin
receptors on
various cells,
certain cells.
and causes glucose
uptake storage
and therefore
removes glucose from
the blood sugar,
lowering blood sugar.
Glucagon also
comes from the
endocrine
pancreas, different
cells, and it
acts at the liver,
causing gluconeogenesis,
synthesis of
glucose, which then
increases blood sugar.
This concept has a
clinical application
because insulin
and glucon are both
available in drug
form. They can be
injected. So for
an individual, a
diabetic, who has
hypoglycemia, this is
a serious adverse
effect of insulin,
glucagon can be
administered to
increase the
synthesis of glucose
in the liver and
counteract the
hypoglycemia, raise
the blood sugar.
Inhaled methicoline
is a drug that's
given as something called
a bronchoprovocation
test for diagnosis
of asthma.
It will act on
muscarinic receptors
in, that's not
a very good M,
muscarinic receptors
in bronchial smooth
muscle and that will
cause contraction or
constriction. We see
that here. The airway is
very narrowed and that
reduces the amount
of air that can get
through the bronchus.
Albuterol must be
kept close at hand
when When
methacholine is being
administered,
albuterol is also
inhaled, and it is
a sympathomimetic.
It acts on beta
-2 adrenergic
receptors. These
are obviously
different types
of receptors.
That will cause bronchial
smooth muscle relaxation,
bronchial dilation,
opening of the airway.
opposite effects two
drugs acting in the
same tissues but on
different receptors
now the chemical
antagonists bind
directly combined
directly with the drug
the typical example
is heparin, which
is a negatively
charged molecule.
When it is given
an overdose, this
is going to be an
accidental problem,
protamine may be
administered to combine
with the heparin.
and protamine is
a protein that's
positively charged.
And then this
combined product
here is inactive,
the heparin is
inactive, and
it is excreted.
Tetracycline is
an antibiotic,
one, two, three,
four, four cycles,
hence the name
tetracycline.
It is chelated by
polyvalent metal
ions, such as are
found in antacids, in
the gut, and therefore
the absorption
is reduced,
significantly reduced.
Cholestyramine has
a similar idea.
Cholestyramine is
not absorbed. It
will sequester
the drug and carry
it out. The drug
is not absorbed.
So those are examples
of functional or
physiologic and
chemical antagonists.
So I'm inviting
you to pause the
video and answer
these questions.
What is the difference
between the two
-state receptor
occupancy model and
the classical receptor
occupancy model
explaining drug
receptor interactions?
And how are antagonists
classified and
what are the effects
on agonist efficacy?
Now would be a
good time to pause.
So you're back now,
and the answer to the
first question is,
the two-state receptor
occupancy model
posits that receptors
in the receptor pool
exist in an inactive
and an active
conformation in the
absence of ligand,
with the equilibrium
favoring the inactive
state. The drug binding
to the receptors
shifts the equilibrium
depending on the drug's
relative affinities
for the active and
inactive states.
And the second question.
The classical model
posits that receptors
in a receptor
pool are quiet,
quiescent, unless
activated by a ligand.
Agonists have affinity
for receptors and
activate the receptors
effector pathways.
Antagonists have
affinity for
receptors but do
not activate the
receptors and they
prevent the agonist
from activating
the receptors.
Competitive
antagonists compete for
the same binding
site as the agonist
and affect the
amount of agonist
needed to achieve
a maximal response.
Non-competitive
antagonists reduce the
magnitude of the maximal
response that can be
achieved by any amount
of agonist without having
an effect on the binding
of the agonist to
the receptor. This is
because the noncompetitive
antagonists either
irreversibly occupy
the active site or more
commonly bind to an
allosteric site, a
site nearby, changing
the shape of the active
site, the confirmation
of the active site,
reducing the affinity
of the receptor for the
drug and vice versa.
Receptor dynamics now.
Everything in
our bodies is
dynamic,
changing, moving,
reaching equilibrium,
falling out of
equilibrium.
And receptor
dynamics is a
cellular regulation
that allows our
bodies to stay
in homeostasis.
Cellular regulation
of drug receptor
interactions prevents
overstimulation that
can harm the cell or
the entire organism.
As a result of
the physiologic
regulation,
many drugs show
diminishing
effects over time.
So we have some
terms here.
A diminished response,
frequently called
tolerance, due to
exposure to an agonist.
Receptor desensitization
is a decrease
in the coupling
efficiency of receptors.
The receptor and
the cell become
unresponsive or
insensitive to the
action of the drug
even in the continued
presence of the
drug. And I will
illustrate this
on the next slide.
Receptor downregulation
is just a decrease
in the number of
receptors which occurs
by internalizing, the
cell internalizing
the receptor drug
complex, and we'll
talk about that on
the next slide too.
When the rate of
receptor degradation
is faster than new
receptor synthesis,
fewer receptors
are present on
the cell surface
and responsiveness
to the agonist
is diminished.
Tachyphylaxis is
an acute, sudden
decrease in response
after continuous or
repeated administration
of the drug.
Now receptor
resensitization occurs
when the agonist is
withdrawn, in other
words the drug
is stopped, cells
recover full responsiveness
to a subsequent
addition of the
agonist, which I
will show you on
the next slide also.
Now there is something
called increased
sensitivity,
supersensitivity.
And this occurs in
the presence of an
antagonist where
there is insertion of
an increased number
of receptors because
of the presence
of the antagonist.
And that can make
the cells more
sensitive to an
agonist. And I'll get to
that, an illustration
of that as well.
Okay, we have panel
A and panel B. Panel
A is on top, panel
B is underneath it.
Panel A you can
see is a curve.
And this is an
example of the beta
receptor that I
referred to before,
which is called
a beta adrenergic
receptor or an
adrenoccepter.
So you can imagine
we're talking
about the beta
receptors on cardiac
tissue. We could
be talking about
beta receptors
in the bronchi.
We could be talking
about other types of
G protein coupled
receptors. measures.
We see that a dose
is given here, full
response, okay,
that's what we expect.
Over time, the effect
diminishes, even
though the same
amount of drug is
being given, to the
point where there's
really a very low
effect. effect.
So this could be
desensitization that's
occurring, downregulation
that's occurring,
and if it happens
fairly rapidly,
we call that
tachyphylaxis.
Now, the drug is stopped.
No drug.
Certain time frame,
whatever it is,
and the drug is
restarted at the
same dose dose, and
achieves the same
maximal effect
after that pause.
But of course tachyphylaxis
happens again.
And we think about that
very frequently with
opioids for example,
opiates, where they
achieve a certain degree
of efficacy initially
and then over time
the patient tends to
become tolerant to
that particular dose,
requiring a larger dose
to get the same effect.
Now let's look at the
mechanism here
on panel B.
Here we have our
agonist drug binding to
the receptor, and
if you count up all
these pass-throughs,
the membrane, you can
see it's the G protein
coupled receptor.
And the agonist
is here and it
activates this
downstream effect.
And at some point
inside the cell it gets
phosphorylated and beta
-arrestins bind here.
And that desensitizes
the receptor. It
will not be able
to respond anymore.
That's the theory
of how it works.
Then this receptor
moves on down here.
Let's say this
is a receptor
and it is being
endocytosed.
And here we have it
down here. You can
see the drug drug and
the receptor are in
the endosome. Now
this can go two ways.
It can be reintroduced
back to the plasma
membrane, drug
binds, we get the
full efficacy again.
Or it can be
degraded in the
lysosome. And when
this happens,
this is called
downregulation, new
receptors need to
be formed and that
can take time.
So that is a
description of receptor
desensitization
downregulation and the effect
is returned after
the drug is withdrawn
for a certain amount
of time, but then
the patient can develop
tolerance again.
So that's receptor
downregulation
with exposure
to an agonist
internalization
and degradation.
Now, receptor
upregulation can occur
in the presence
of an antagonist.
So an antagonist now
binds to the receptors
and we have here
an example, you see
this is an antagonist
here and all these
receptors are bound by
the antagonist and the
agonist cannot
activate the receptors.
Now of course, there
are going to be more
than three receptors
on a membrane and there
will be certainly
way, way, way more,
tens of thousands
more, maybe hundreds of
thousands more agonist
molecules in there.
But this simple
example really
serves to demonstrate
the concept.
So the cell responds.
The cell recognizes
that its receptors
are nonfunctional
and it responds
by inserting more
receptors on the
surface and here we have
the agonist binding
to the receptor.
Now let's say the drug is
withdrawn at this point,
we have, let's say
there's another receptor
here, we have twice
as many receptors
on the plasma membrane
compared to normally.
The drug is withdrawn.
All this drug goes away.
Now the agonist
comes out and it can
bind six receptors
instead of three
receptors. So the
response is going to
be much exaggerated
compared to normal
once the antagonist
is withdrawn.
So this membrane now
is super sensitive.
Now let's say we
have an example
again of our beta
blocker blocking
our beta receptors
receptors,
and more receptors
have been deposited
on the cell
membrane because we
have that antagonist
present. Now the
beta blocker is
abruptly withdrawn.
The patient's
been taking it for
a long time,
body got used to
the beta receptor
being there,
and all of a sudden,
in a matter of hours,
all of those receptors
are freed up.
And what's going to
bind to those receptors?
norepinephrine and
epinephrine, and what
can happen? The
supersensitive response, the
hyper-response increase
in blood pressure,
the patient can get a
hypertensive problem.
Again I invite you to
pause the computer.
How does receptor
desensitization and
downregulation
affect response to a
natural or drug
agonist? And, how does
receptor
supersensitivity affect
response to a natural
or drug agonist?
Please pause if you wish.
Well, you're back now,
so the answer to the
first question is
desensitization and down
regulation cause a
diminished response to
continuous or repeated
exposure to an agonist
that can lead to
fewer receptors or
desensitized receptors on
the cell surface. After
withdrawal of the drug,
cells recover full
responsiveness to a
subsequent addition of
the agonist. They
undergo resensitization.
Now supersensitivity,
continuous or repeated
exposure to an
antagonist can cause
upregulation of receptors
and insertion of an
increased number of
receptors on cell surfaces.
After the antagonist
is withdrawn, the
increased receptor
density can result
in an exaggerated
response to a natural
or drug agonist,
supersensitivity.
And our final topic,
pharmacodynamic
variability in
a population.
The response to a
drug, the effect,
is specified to
be either present
or absent in a
given individual.
It's an either
or event, which
is called a
quantal event.
Determining the dose
of a drug required to
produce a specified
effect, it has to be
specified in advance,
in a large number of
individual patients,
as in a clinical
trial, or experimental
animal and plotting the
quantal dose response
can be used to
generate some information
on the margin of
safety to be expected
for a particular drug.
To be expected,
remembering that each
individual is an
individual. And there can be
individual differences
between patients.
So we have our
figure here
on the right hand side.
And we have our
bell curve here.
cumulative curve here.
Now, each of these
individuals is given
a dose of a drug
and then observed to
see if the pre-specified
response occurs.
So we talk about,
let's say, sedation.
So the response
we're looking for
is sedation. And
at this low dose,
a few individuals have
exhibited sedation.
And at this dose, a
few more individuals.
And at this
dose, 50% of the
individuals have
exhibited sedation.
And on, and at this dose,
finally, all of the
individuals have
exhibited sedation. Now
look at this spread.
Some individuals
were sedated here,
half the individuals were
sedated at this
point, the ED50,
the dose at which 50% of
the individuals
responded,
and some of the
individuals did not
respond at all until
this high dose.
Now, thinking about
an even higher dose
that's given, we're
talking about toxicity now.
Whatever that endpoint
toxicity is with
animal studies, it
might be death, for
example. In clinical
trials, trials, it might
be the appearance of
a particular toxicity.
So if it's death,
this is lethal dose at
which 50% of the
individuals had died.
And if we're
talking about a
clinical trial,
for example,
it would be toxic
dose, 50, the point
at which 50% of
the individuals
demonstrated the pre
-specified toxicity.
Here a few of
the individuals
experienced the toxicity.
Here, 50% of the
individuals, or I should
say death, that's what
we're talking about
here, LD50, of the
individuals had died
at this concentration.
And at this
concentration, all of
the individuals had died.
So you can see there's
a big spread in
the concentration
that produced the pre
-specified effect in
different individuals.
Now what do we, how can
we use this information?
Well the therapeutic
index is an
estimate of the safety
of a drug, and I
have another figure
to show you this.
The median effective
dose, the ED50, is
the dose of a drug
required to produce
a specified effect
in 50% of the
population. So, these
are repeated concepts.
Median lethal
dose, the LD50,
is the dose of
a drug that is
lethal in 50% of
the population.
Median toxic dose,
the TD50, is the dose
of a drug that
produces a specified
toxic effect in 50%
of the population. it.
The therapeutic index
relates the dose of
the drug required to
produce the specified
effect to the dose
that produces the
undesired effect. So
it's a relationship
between the the benefit
and the unbenefit,
the undesired effect.
LD50 or TD50 are
experimentally defined
by the following.
Therapeutic index
equals the LD50 divided
by the ED50 or the
toxic dose 50 divided
by the ED50. Same
concept. A large
therapeutic index
indicates a wide margin. So
if the LD50 is here,
and the ED50 is here,
we have this margin
of safety in here.
Now, a small
therapeutic index, say
the LD50 is here,
and the ED50 is here,
compared Compared to
that other one, we
see we only have a
narrow range of safety.
And this range of
safety is referred
to as the
therapeutic window.
Looking at our
cumulative curves
again, here's our
ED50, 50% of the
individuals have
already already achieved
that desired
beneficial effect.
The rest of them
will achieve it
somewhere in this
therapeutic window,
but a few of them
will actually
be above the
therapeutic window,
and we see that this
is actually a dose
for some that's in
the toxic range.
Here, some individuals
will have already
experienced the toxic
effect or even died
even though the
concentrations in the
therapeutic window. Some
individuals are just
more sensitive relative
to the drug effect.
The therapeutic window
represents the range
of steady state
concentrations at which
the likelihood of
efficacy is high and
the probability of
adverse effects is low.
So it's just a
starting point.
This range does not
guarantee safety
or efficacy in
individual patients.
And in fact,
it wasn't even
efficacious in
these patients.
What is the clinical
value of the
therapeutic index and
the therapeutic window?
I think you can
answer this even
without pausing your
computer. But you, if
you wish to, certainly
think about it.
The therapeutic
index relates the
dose of a drug
required to produce
a desired effect
to the dose
that produces an
undesired effect.
It is an estimate,
estimate.
The therapeutic
window is the dose
range of a drug that
provides safe and
effective therapy
with minimal adverse
effects. It does
not guarantee safety
or efficacy in the
individual patient.
Optimize therapy for
the individual patient.
So how do you do
this? You have
to take a very good,
careful history
and that will
help guide you.
So in summary,
we have our
pharmacodynamics
is the study of the
effects on the
biologic systems.
We have our two-state
receptor occupancy
model that postulates
that receptors
in the receptor pool
exist in equilibrium
in two interchangeable
conformational
states in the
absence of a ligand.
Remember this is one
type of receptor.
The active
conformation and
the inactive
conformation.
Full agonists,
partial agonists,
neutral antagonists,
and inverse
agonists are explained
by this model.
Many drugs actually
do represent
this model, but
many drugs do not.
The classical receptor
occupancy model
postulates that
receptors are quiescent,
quiet, unless
activated by a ligand.
Agonists occupy
receptors, activate
their regulatory
effector mechanisms,
and produce a
response. Agonists
have affinity and
intrinsic activity.
Antagonists occupy
receptors, but do not
activate them, they
have affinity, zero
intrinsic allergic
activity and prevent the
agonist from occupying
the site of action.
Receptor antagonists
are classified as
competitive and
noncompetitive antagonists,
irreversible, and
allosteric modulators.
Positive allosteric
modulators increase
agonist affinity or
magnitude of effect.
But negative allosteric
modulators reduce
affinity and or
efficacy of the agonist.
Physiologic or
functional antagonism
results from
counterbalancing effects
on physiologic
regulatory pathways
by substances
acting at different
receptors or by
different mechanisms.
Chemical antagonists
sequester the agonist,
preventing it from
binding its receptors.
Cellular regulation
of drug receptor
interactions
can alter the
response to the
agonist over time.
Diminished
responsiveness, which is
tolerance,
tachyphylaxis, due to
continuous or repeated
repeated exposure
to an agonist
results in receptor
desensitization
and downregulation.
After withdrawal
of the agonist, the
cells recover full
responsiveness
to a subsequent
addition of agonist,
and this is called
resensitization.
An increased
density of membrane
receptors can result
from continuous
or repeated exposure
to an antagonist
after the antagonist
is withdrawn.
Activation by
the agonist can
cause an exaggerated
response.
Individuals in a
population vary in their
response to the same
concentration of a
single drug or similar
drugs, and a given
individual may not
always respond in the
same way to the same
drug concentration.
Quantal dose response
curves describes
the cumulative frequency
distributions of
responders defined
as an all or none
effect plotted against
the log dose of a
drug. The percentage
of the population
affected increases as
the dose is raised.
The parameters for
calculating the therapeutic
index are the dose
of drug required
to produce an effect in
50% of the population,
ED50, and the
dose that produces
death or toxicity in
50% of the population.
The therapeutic
index is an
estimate, that's
all it is, an
estimate of the
drug's safety.
The therapeutic
window is a range of
steady state
concentrations at which the
likelihood hood of
efficacy is high and the
probability of adverse
effects is low.
And that concludes
this lecture,
the series on
pharmacodynamics.